hey what's up guys my name is eterno and
welcome to episode 9 yes
episode 9 sorry completely forgot that
that's how long it's been okay before I
continue with episode 9 of network
chattering I just wanted to say that um
I'm gonna be focusing a bit more heavily
on this series first okay and the reason
is obviously the game programming series
is gonna take forever to finish because
you know I don't even know if it will
finish okay it's kind of like a
minecraft let's play in that sense right
you can just keep playing it
same thing with game programming right
it's just I don't even know what it's
gonna and honestly because there's an
infinite amount of things that we could
add to that game now as for this though
this is gonna finish pretty soon I'm
thinking like 30 or so episodes maybe
even less so because of that I'm
probably just gonna focus on this
because this is what I finished this is
what I want to finish before we start
multiplayer for game programming since
this is kind of like the reason I
thought I started this series to UM to
demonstrate how sockets and you know the
different protocols work for sending
data over a network but um that being
said we're gonna hop in and we're gonna
do a pretty quick episode today and I'll
show you guys exactly what I mean by um
about what's going on I guess but um if
we just do our standard stuff here you
know localhost whatever port a one on
one line to none that matters here login
you know we're gonna have been
connecting here it's all good we got
focus on this and if we element just
move it so you guys can see and if I
start typing this is probably my
recording area isn't it if I start
typing like you know hey what's up guys
I want to be able to hit answer right
right now I just have to hit Send and
what it does is absolutely nothing right
now but what I want to do is when I hit
enter or when I hit Send I actually want
to be able to get this text and push it
into this little console that we have
here okay let's do that to do that we're
going to go to our well okay letlet
let's first of all hop into our design
right because remember that's we're
using um that the window builder plug-in
here in order to give us a way to
actually you know drag-and-drop and view
our changes and and
essentially design our frame instead of
having to code the entire thing so I've
got here is the send button okay all I'm
gonna just want to click on the send
button I'm gonna right click and I'm
going to go to a set action
no wait night hang on add event handler
sorry and then action and then action
performed okay
so add event handler action and then
action performed and then when I click
on that and what's going to do is it's
going to get football back into our code
view and you see there's actually added
this code over here and what it's doing
is this the J button of course this is
the J button object it's adding an
action listener to it now what an action
listener is is essentially it listens
for a specified action so what happens
is in in a button for example the action
performed is the click on it right
that's what you do with a button of
course you can handle other things with
it such as if the mouse is hovering over
it and other stuff of that but a buttons
action is when it's clicked so what
we've done is we've actually added a
guess an action listener so that we can
now actually tell our code we can
actually I guess execute code when that
action is performed and in this case
force because it's a button it's clicked
so when we do click let's do something
so one thing that we want to do is
actually of course push into our console
what we've just said so how do we do
that so first of all let's break this
down right what we need to get is the
string of text the we've just typed
because if I run this if I run our thing
real quick here and just put in our
standard parameters hit login you know
I'm going to type something like hey
what's up you know my name is the Cherno
blah blah blah right this is the text
that we want to get we want to get this
text and we want to actually put it into
here okay when we hit the send button so
let's let's talk about how we can do
that now that text field of course is
called a where is it it's called a text
message I think is it yes
yep jtextfield it's called text message
okay so what we want to get is we want
to get our message here which is
going to be equal to text message dot
get text okay and what that will do is
of course return a string of the text
that is in that text field so we've got
that so now what we can do is actually
put it into our cons all right we've got
a method here called console and
essentially it takes a parameter which
is message and it appends whatever we
type into the console so all we have to
do is type console message okay and
that's it it's gonna it's gonna put it's
gonna actually you know print our
message into our console and of course
that's well that's pretty much it isn't
it so let's try and run that it's not
pretty much it I just want to show you
guys what happens though localhost a
one-nighter login so hey what's up and
then so hey what's up and then among hit
and I'm on the click send brilliant so
it appears here right problem it does
not disappear from here okay now that's
important of course you don't want to
keep your message there so what what we
should do is once we do print it let's
actually clear it so text message dot
set text to just blank okay I don't
think there's a clear or anything I
don't remember I don't think there is
though from my memory there might be but
this works as well okay I'm pretty sure
that's not though so what you can do is
just set text to be nothing okay so if
we run this now
Jana like will host a one man to log in
whoa that did not work
I opened mail sorry I'm gonna have to
get rid of that whoops okay so if we
type something hey what's up and then we
hit Send
it disappears okay awesome now what we
want to do is make enter work and that's
really simple as well luckily so over
here in design what you'll actually see
is that in our little thing here right
out
next message jtextfield here if we
right-click and again we'll go to the
add event handler menu you can probably
guess what I want to do here there's a
little a little something called key and
keep pressed so what we can do is we can
actually listen for if a key on the
keyboard is pressed so let's click on
that it'll hop us back into our code
view and pump in a kill list and we can
get rid of the override it doesn't
actually do anything it's just like a
flag what we can do here now is
basically what no to do whatever we want
so we could be like okay if the user
types in you know the letter A let's
just lock him out and get rid of the
application we could do that right don't
know it would but the point is you can
okay because but now we're listening for
key presses so so if and remember our
key event here is e so if e get K code
right is essentially equal to the key
code for enter which we could just type
the number or you could just go key
event dot a fake fake a virtual keyboard
enter yeah so if the if the key that
we've typed is the Enter key then what
what you know we can eiseley do what we
did here now this is where it comes to
the point where you know copying and
pasting this code is probably not good
ok probably not a good idea just because
if we want to change something I'll have
to change it everywhere so what we could
do instead is actually make a universal
method here called
send now the reason I'm type there is an
I'm um pulling it's and by the way is
because of course in the future it will
actually send to all the other clients
or will actually it'll send to the
server ok but for now it'll only you
know sent to our thing so and I'll put a
message in here ok so that is fairly
universal method yeah and we could
probably make it private
ok at least for now so now that we've
got that all we have to do is grab this
code and paste it in to send we can get
rid of actually let's just copy this
text message like get text since that's
what well that's what we'll be using as
a parameter and then we can just do that
ok simple as that
we'll just remove that line and over
here you know in our sand a button when
when we click our send button we'll just
type in send and then text message get
text right and then over here when in
the enter key I'll do the same thing
send and then the parameter is text
message to get text okay there you go
pretty simple isn't it so now if we run
what should hopefully happen once we
type in our stuff here 7-1-8-2 does not
matter I could just be something I could
just do something like hey what's up
what's up bro and then I can hit hit
enter and notice it sends and then of
course I can do that repeatedly as you
can see now if we just hit enter it'll
actually um send that as you can see and
whoa that went down there we'll talk
about that next week
sorry next week what am I talking about
tomorrow probably let's quickly fix that
by the way so send in text messages or
get text we can just do something like
if you know our message is actually
equal to nothing then we can actually
just return so don't send it if it's
blank
right no point so let's run that again
and see what that does
I don't know if it'll work or not
because string is going to be a bit
interesting when you can pair them with
normal operators so we'll we'll see but
you know hey okay see how it still works
it still sends even though it's nothing
that's a little thing in Java which I'm
personally not a big fan of but this
equals stuff does not always work with
strings sometimes it does which annoys
me but sometimes it doesn't so what we
need to do instead of if message is
equal to blank what we need to do is say
if message dot equals and I failed
typing that if message dot equals that
right then return so let's try that and
that will hopefully work so you know
stuff again as usual so hey
and you notice that I'm hitting enter
here and it's not actually creating
spaces so I can hit enter as many times
as I want anymore and actually send it
unless there's something to send okay so
that is that that's gonna wrap up this
episode of never chef programming before
it does though let me just do one more
thing we've got the name of our client
of our guy here which is I think yarn in
this case over here into a message you
know let's just pop up let's just pop
down message
you know actually message equals name
right Plus that thing plus a colon
plus a colon and plus our actual message
okay something like that and that'll
what that will do is of course just
append I guess the name to the starts
isn't really appending but it'll put the
name of the person who says this at the
start so it will look more like a chalk
line I guess and you could also get the
date and time or whatever but that's
really up to you
so figure hey you can see it but it puts
my name in front here and you can see
that there's never gonna be a blank
space that I send even if I had send so
yeah that is gonna wrap up episode 9 of
my programming hope you guys did enjoy
it again if you did please hit the like
button too and relax one video per day
300 likes equals two videos per day
let's get this plus it let's just get to
300 likes so we finished this series up
quicker so we can really focus 100% on
game programming and start implementing
multiplayer for gamberoni because I'm
looking forward to doing that that's
gonna be a lot of fun but either way
guys
I will see you guys next time goodbye